was the show real no one ever handed me
a script
done thank you abby they would tell us
we had to fight or we weren't going to
go to dinner when i hadn't had i was
really mad which you were not cause
you didn't show up to do your job no one
knew
it was gonna be such a phenom i am the
best thing
far page but yeah guess what my daughter
was a
wreck all freaking week my girls haven't
ever danced
since the day we left that show it was
that bad for them
[Music]
the producers were the one that actually
made the pyramid get lost [ __ ]
so at the beginning we had to pretend
shut up kelly
i'm keeping my mouth over here the
cameras never captured that
they never captured it a comment like
that is gonna get you fired
deal with it we are the original dance
moms here reuniting with e.t
welcome dance moms i'm so excited to
talk with you today
we are going to be covering everything
aldc
and beyond introduce yourselves and who
your daughters are
i'm melissa and my daughters are maddie
and mackenzie ziegler
and they are 16 and almost 18 now
i'm holly hatcher frazier known as dr
holly and i
am the mother of mia who many know from
dance moms who is 19.
hi i'm kelly hyland i have brooke who is
21 and paige who is 19.
and i am joe vertez and kendall is my
baby
who was on dance moms with me and she is
now
17 years old wow i i cannot believe time
has flown like this i remember watching
dance moms
with my mom my mom was also a dance mom
so that was our bonding but jess was
your mom
a dance mom i'm sure she wished that
she had the guts to say some of the
things that you guys did
i don't know if it was guts or stupidity
but okay exactly
like that's better you stupid
you know what no one said yes really
first of all let's get into why you're
all here your podcast because mom said
so
what inspired the decision to start a
podcast so i
was thinking um about all the ladies and
i thought we should do something
together the
moms have had we've had such a great
bond together and our girls still have
an amazing bond and so do we so i called
all the gals and said hey can we get
together
so we decided to get together and we
brainstormed
and we thought it'd be really fun to get
together and do a project
what kind of things are you going to be
covering on the podcast we talk about
really no topics are off limits with us
as usual
we like to give advice and we like to
tell stories there were you know a ton
of iconic fights
on the dance monks the show so are we
gonna get a little bit of that in the
podcast or we all just like smooth
sailing from
oh gosh no there's no fighting we're not
fighting our fights we're like
they would tell us we had to fight or we
weren't going to go to dinner were there
any moments when that actually got real
oh yeah oh
oh yeah i liked when you got mad holly
just saying
abby i would not go there this is
ridiculous i think you've lost your mind
i was gonna say you're a lawyer
the emotions were totally real the tears
were real
the anger all of it was real because
really
we were protecting our children i love
that you're all still super close but i
can't help but notice there's a
certain mom missing here is there are
you guys so close with christy
absolutely absolutely christy kelly i
know you two are very close
are you still in canada yes we are
actually but yeah i
talk to her all the time so what's the
reason why you think
fans of the show should listen to the
podcast well
as my husband would say we got a lot to
say yeah
i mean we're funny together like when
it's all of us together
it's just we start on one little subject
and it just goes
yeah and i think it's nice that people
get to see you know the real
the real us of course and you know our
kids have grown up in the spotlight and
just to show they're normal all of our
kids are such
normal human beings and i also think a
lot of our fans and followers
are invested in us and they're invested
in our kids lives they've watched them
grow up and they've grown up with our
kids and we've
all have evolved as women we're not the
same women that we were
we you on a castle dance moms i think we
want to share that with people and
people are interested and we thank them
for that
if i was on the show now it wouldn't be
good i probably would be kicked off the
show
well you guys definitely had to go
through a lot and you went through it
together
which is why i assume you're so so close
take me back to how the show got started
well it's interesting to think that far
back because that's almost
a decade um but the show started really
as this idea when i first heard about
the show i honestly did not think it was
real
i thought who would ever watch a quality
show
from pittsburgh
and why remember going in with mia to
audition for the show
and i let her do her own hair and makeup
because once again i did not think it
was real so the girls did audition
for the show and then from there i think
three months later we got a call while
we were eating dinner
that we were cast for the show and i
remember we left the audition i told mia
they will never pick us for this show
because we are too boring
[Laughter]
well and then they gave us they handed
us these little
cameras and they told us what to film
you know us as a group
i don't think they originally wanted our
dance studio they were going all over
the country and they were going to get
just kids from different studios but
then they just liked
our you know art is it going to be a
quiet day up here
are we talking to each other how did
your families react they thought it was
a joke too don't you think guys
six episodes and they're like if you
don't sign this paperwork right now
you're not gonna be on it and we're like
i remember calling kelly i'm like are we
signing this
[Laughter]
well jess it no one knew it was gonna be
such a phenom
you know like i came on on season two
they had reached out for me and kendall
to
audition and originally it was supposed
to be for a couple episodes
because each season really we never
really knew
how how many episodes they were going to
shoot
at least early on like it just kept
going and going and going and
that you know you'd sign on for six
episodes and then they'd make you sign a
contract for
23 more we would shoot up to 36
episodes a season you must have been
exhausted
yes well that's why we were crazy
yeah but we didn't win our it was an
opportunity for the kids like i think
all of us we didn't do it for we did it
for the channel
you know we wanted them they enjoyed it
and
and we wanted them to see what it was
like to travel
literally we traveled around the world
having our kids dance it was a great
opportunity
and i think people didn't expect that no
one could have predicted the success of
the show and it really
changed the landscape of reality tv with
children in it
as well as dance and i think for some
things for the better but
i don't think our families could have
predicted that we certainly didn't yet
never expecting it would be years long
like it was hard for us who had
other children at home because we would
travel
every weekend and be working every night
and
our children who weren't on the show
were without their moms
and that that was difficult what is one
question that you would say
fans ask you the most about your
experience
is it real i think the the question that
fans ask
the most i think is was the show real
what was it for me it's real for me
because people want to know because it's
scripted and i will say no one ever
handed me a script
which are are loosely scripted ours
wasn't we never got a script
we never got a script but they knew what
they wanted every week
and what happened you up i mean and
that's what really reality shows did you
know the producers would have three
story lines that they really manipulated
us
to get to you know um they would create
these story lines just from listening to
us talking we had those mics on for 20
12 hours a day so they would hear us
talking our personal conversations with
our friends
or our children on our phones home to
our husbands
so they knew what was going on in our
lives
and i know for me it took me a while to
figure that out i'm like
how'd they know that oh they heard me
talking on the phone
at some point they probably caught you
saying
something that actually did turn into a
real fight because
right i think absolutely they did that
like they gave all the moms a letter
from me i think it was an
invoice for something all of the moms
received a letter from an attorney
saying to cease and desist discussion of
melissa's personal life
so it's like you know yeah yeah i do i
remember that
yeah they created situations to get us
all wound up
right to get them going and no one knew
is there anything like could you not
talk about that during the time of
filming of course but they cut
they can edit you the any way they want
to edit you yeah there were a lot of
things
said not in the context where they had a
saying
remember when cute like kira for
instance threw a bottle
at a camera person or a producer you're
trying to make
up to cause drama so walk
that way it was so funny and it made it
look like she was throwing it at one of
us and she was oh but she was mad she
was mad at the producer she whipped the
bottle and they made it look like she
was throwing it at jess
and she didn't i do love the cutaways
that your faces
those are i continue our eye rolls and
well i'm going to take you on a little
trip down memory lane here
maybe it's just me but every time kathy
and the candy apples came around
we walk in and there's caffeine
a potter bag i don't have time for my
enemy
i don't want to look at that woman i got
a little bit excited
okay christy can come after me get out
oh my god you're gonna hit me with your
purse
yeah obviously jill you went over there
for a little bit look at jill's face
jill you have to answer this question
because she's your bff
not to my liking i had no choice kathy
was the antagonist of the show
don't say anything about my child
ever again the producers loved kathy and
vivi
i pretty much took center stage and i
improvised what is she doing this is my
opinion
vivi didn't even like to dance do you
know what i mean like our kids were
dancers they would
when the cameras were off they were
there till midnight still practicing
because they
wanted to be good they wanted to look at
vivi didn't
vivi did it because her mom really
wanted her to
but the producers loved kathy and they
wanted her
in those shows at any cost so they
shipped me
over there you know i didn't want to be
there
and kathy and i never really cared much
for each other
so at the beginning we had to pretend
shut up kelly
i'm keeping my mouth set over here all
right kathy here's your costume
help the rhinestones give your daughter
some luck yeah
uh yeah kathy was kathy was tough
she was tough she didn't like me because
i kind of feel like i saw her
for who she was she was using the system
she just wanted to be on tv
and wanted her kid on tv that's just my
opinion i think kathy was there
for all the wrong reasons just to be an
idiot and you know
drive all of us nuts and it worked
it worked i didn't need to do that
either
i will say she was entertaining yeah i
know
people loved her she's a really nice
woman in real life because we still get
too much
um and she's i always tell people that
really
ask about her i always say kathy is very
different
like talking to her in real life than
what she appears on the show if she
turns into like
like a cat or something when the cameras
come on it's really funny
you guys are cracking me up well i want
to also
bring up the iconic pyramid let's move
on to the pyramid
was that pyramid set up specifically for
the show
and did that ever draw a wedge between
your girls i think the beginning
might have bothered them but then i
think towards the end of the show
like after season two they were like oh
this pyramid is just for the show
so you know but i think in the beginning
it did bother them
since brook's not in the pyramid does
that mean she's not going this weekend
well
and then they figured out that the
producers were the one that actually
made the
pyramid and sometimes we would wait for
hours to go into pyramid
because abby would be fighting with the
producers and then you know the pyramid
i mean then we'd stand there for five
hours literally i mean that was the
worst day of the week for the girls and
for us
and yeah all the fights happened on
pyramid day you're exactly right yeah
but we've all you said something mean to
my face about mine
i said it to you i did not say it it
doesn't make it
okay well that we all have done it and
we need to move on
a lot of them a lot of them but it
always started with abby being angry
with the producers because she didn't
like either a storyline
or the title of because that's when she
would give out
you have a solo you have a duet these
people are in the group
and she and the producers would
determine that
and abby never never agreed to it i'm
abby the miller
i know what i'm doing she always wanted
to change
their plans their pyramid their solos
so we would wait we would come sit ready
to film
and sit there sometimes for hours
waiting for abby
and the and the producers to put their
fighting and arguing
and how many times guys did she storm
out
get in her car pull away and we're
sitting there
an hour two later she comes back
right yeah i think the idea about the
pyramid and pyramid day which usually
was wednesdays for us was
the pyramid but we never before had a
pyramid actually in the studio but i
think
it represented the idea in her mind of
who was on top and who was on bottom
as arbitrary as it could be i think the
pyramid always existed but it wasn't
in a visual form yeah right right now if
you're in
the bottom line of the pyramid i think
abby's trying to tell you something
so i think it was very real but the
seeing it
play out in reality is a really
different experience
and i think when what to the the ladies
are saying is
absolutely if there was a disagreement
about who would be placed or who would
get a certain assignment
more so because if it wasn't a directive
then some kids would never
dance and would never see others spot on
the permit except for the bottom
so i think there had to be someone else
looking out sometimes because otherwise
some people would be absolutely
neglected
yeah yeah you're right i agree very much
agreed on that
get out i kind of want to draw your
attention to that actually holly you
brought up
something interesting and i'm going to
direct this toward you and jill
why did you stick around for so long
people do ask that from time to time and
i think some people don't understand
whatever you're doing double it i don't
want anyone in my children's lives to
dictate to them
you leave because i'm forcing you out or
because you're not wanted it's your
choice and i always make
me a choice whenever you're ready to
leave we can leave so that's the reason
why we stayed
yeah my kids were ready to leave
so that's why we left and like i had had
enough so
that's why we left and we left season
six because my girl said they didn't
want to do it anymore and i said okay
then we'll leave you stay because you
you have to take the
good with the bad and it wasn't always
bad there was a lot of good
too i mean the kids walked on red
carpets they met
superstars they won you know nickelodeon
awards they got to
you know sing and and have number one
songs
so for me and kendall there were times
when
i said okay i think we're done and
and it was hard the producers wouldn't
let you just
walk away but then you know kendall
would say well yeah but i really are
going to fight like me and then you can
get out
i had to smack abby and pull her hair
girl's out the room yeah
so bottom line is you have to take the
good with the bad
and and i think i don't i don't have any
regrets for staying
as long as we did and keep in mind
season eight they wanted us back
and we were like yeah now we're done
like once the minis came on
then we were totally finished no we
wanted to leave for sure
my kids had just had it i have had it um
you know my kids personalities really
changed
um my kids used to be so happy to be at
dance and
they just every day got knocked down and
knocked down and i just
saw it changing them and i didn't want
them to have to deal with that anymore
and they didn't want to do it anymore
so that was basically why we left i want
to go home
paige was frightened because abby is a
400 pound woman and threw a chair with
my daughter in the room
you can credit me for the rest of my
tuition for the month
and rip off my credit card number i was
sad kelly was going with the girls
um but you know it was time for her
did they ever miss it like once you guys
have laughter
never no and mike it like i said
they it totally changed their lives my
girls haven't ever danced since the day
we left that show
it was like it ruined their whole
perspective of dance
and reality tv like
they don't want to be on another show
they like even if they were at like they
just don't want
to be in that environment anymore it was
that bad to are them of control
let's shift gears to the woman who
cannot be stopped abby leaves are any of
you still in contact with her today
no not me i wouldn't say i'm not in
contact with abby
but now occasionally she'll she'll jump
out on
on my instagram and and say something
but
i don't i'm not in contact with her
but she lives in la i live in pittsburgh
i don't i don't see
her you want to leave leave this is a
new phase this is a new chapter
to your story i love that you guys are
writing the narrative with the podcast
now like you're turning the page you are
talking about your friendship now which
was never a centerpiece exactly right
yeah
now we have this friendship and we've
got so much to say and so many
stories and things going on and we're
raising our children
you know yeah i mean we are always here
for each other which is great
um like if i ever needed one of the moms
i know i can call and say oh my gosh i
need help with this
and they would all be there and that's
how we are for each other
and so are our girls i mean our girls
are always there for each other and it's
it's pretty darn badness maddie was
laughing in the day and i'm like who are
you talking to she just brooke
i'm like what are you talking about she
says mom you know so
i'm broke you might not want to know
that i probably don't want to know but
it's really a great friendship that we
have and the
kids there goes joe
that is jill she is so funny sorry
i'm so sorry there's a cult following
around your
these amazing women that you've raised
do you think it was all worth it i think
that you know being on the show was
for sure worth it i mean it was um hard
but it was so much fun and these girls
have lasting friendships
as well as we do um our kids are all
very successful and
very kind humble sweet individuals so
i mean i think we're really blessed i
think the kids personalities for the
first couple years they were very young
but their personalities were stifled a
little bit they weren't allowed
you know there's a funny one and there's
a you know there's so much
to each one of these kids that people
didn't
see the real children they were babies
they
they
went through puberty on national
television yeah talk about don't talk
back
you know like like they had brook be the
miserable teenager all the time and she
always looked grumpy
brook was never miserable she always was
smiling
i mean they had so much fun together and
i wish people saw that
remember they would order like filet
mignons and baked potatoes yeah i'd
order
500 worth of food and never eat it
oh it's just a shame melissa like when
you saying that makes me smile and it's
sad that they never captured that
the cameras never captured that um
they never captured it and let's get an
update on all of your girls
my girls are 16 and 18. um i think
they're they're doing so great
maddie is actually moving out on october
15th which is
crazy to me she's going to be 18. she
just got her new place
um and um mckenzie is doing so great um
she's
singing up a storm recording doing lots
of projects so
my most important thing is that they're
kind humans mia
is in l.a a wide variety of things
bold and the beautiful she was a regular
cast member on that she supported some
music
um now she's a full-time student at ucla
and she has some other projects that are
coming up as well but
for me i'm just really proud of the
young woman that she's becoming and that
she's taking
this adventurous spirit brooke is living
in la
she graduated a year early from ou with
a double major
and immediately moved to la and got a
job there
and paige is um she's an apartment at
west virginia she's going to wvu she's a
sophomore
and they're both doing great enjoying
life
kendall is um she's my youngest she's
17.
when we left la i put her back in our
public school
she is in her senior year and she's
really keeping busy even with covid and
everything it's kind of
um a little bit of a let down for her
senior year she's still singing and
dancing
and performing when she can we
you know she's an influencer we do
auditions in la when we can
and i'm just trying to give her a normal
finish up to her childhood and then you
know she wants to go off to college
so we're applying for colleges now and
we'll see what the future holds
well how do you all feel about the show
seemingly ending now
if it were to come back in some capacity
would you
you know pop in no way
honestly i feel like my story's been
told and by the end of
my season seven when our contract was up
i
i
told a lot of the moms that were coming
on like no need to fight with me
i'm just here to finish telling my story
and i think
everything we've needed to say has been
told and well
on a good on a good note and i'm happy
i'm proud
i have no regrets very thankful and
blessed but
our story has been told what's the one
thing you would want
fans to take away from the show and from
your relationship in general um can i
just say
sometimes you know i'll meet someone
a fan or someone will come and say oh my
gosh are you kendall's mom are you
dancing
and and i don't they can't judge us
the moms or the children from what they
saw on tv and i know that you guys saw
over 200 episodes of these kids but they
really just just give them a chance to
get to know them
don't judge them or think you know them
from something you saw on reality tv
you know what i mean i i think all of us
are just
normal moms who want the best for our
kids my
lesson that i learned from the show
would be to stay true to yourself
because if you're authentic
it's you you have nothing to apologize
for being you because that is who you
are
so as long as you stay true to yourself
and you're authentic and you're
transparent
no regrets this has been a like
beyond treat for me i am so
happy to finally be able to talk with
you all since i watched you for so many
seasons
so thank you so much for being thank you
for having us
i am so happy and thank you everyone for
watching
and make sure to take a listen to
because mom said so
wherever you listen to your podcasts all
right thank you
thank you girls i miss you guys
you